I discovered that something that was
unimaginable just a few years ago
is happening now.
Chinese and American scientists collaborating to secure nuclear materials--
uranium --from the far corners of the globe.
I'm Rich Stone
I'm the international news editor at
Science Magazine.
My story for the Pulitzer Center
is about Chinese and American scientists working together
to save the world
This is really part of my beat at Science
I have a rather unusual beat
it's weapons of mass destruction
and particularly difficult countries to report from
such as Iran and North Korea
Even though I lived in China for 5 years
I never got permission to go to China's
nuclear weapons design laboratories.
It's a real object of frustration for me
I thought well how can i nibble at the
edges of the story?
20 years ago there was a report in the US Congress
about Chinese spying in the nuclear complex
it was allegations of spying that China
vehemently denied
but because of that report
American scientists had been
barred
from the Chinese Academy of Engineering physics.
There's been no collaboration practically speaking for the past 20 years.
So the fact that they're getting together now is pretty significant.
So for the story I reported from Beijing
and from Accra, Ghana.
I visited a new center for excellence in nuclear security
that the US and the Chinese
worked together to establish
pretty amazing complex
they have a bunker where nuclear materials
--special nuclear materials--are stored
I got to go inside the bunker with the scientists there.
The first thing you notice going in: the
razor wire-- curlicues of razor wire--
hanging from the ceiling.
The scientists pointed to a yellow line just
a few inches from from my feet and
said if you step past that line
the razor wire falls down on you.
He was joking.
It wouldn't fall down on you but
what happens with the razor wire is it's lowered to the floor when staff are not there
at an operating nuclear facility storing nuclear materials like this
it's one measure to slow any potential nuclear smugglers.
So ever since 9/11 the US government has been very concerned
about securing loose nukes, first of all nuclear weapons
and also any nuclear materials in countries
that are not one of the nuclear weapon states.
And there's a lot of this nuclear
material out there.
So the US has worked throughout Eastern Europe
to move out highly enriched uranium.
There are smaller amounts that are also scattered
around the globe
including at research reactors that China produced
in the 1980s and 1990s and shipped to
5 countries.
It's a very unusual kind of research reactor
These reactors are in Ghana, Nigeria, Iran,
Pakistan, and Syria.
It's not really necessary at this point
to have that kind of weapons-usable nuclear fuel
The reason that is not necessary now is
that Chinese and American scientists
worked together for 10 years on a project
to redesign the reactor core of the
miniature neutron source reactor to
convert it to run on low enriched
uranium which cannot be used for a
nuclear weapon unless it's further
enriched and that's not easy to do and
so Ghana was the first reactor outside
China to be converted.
I was in Ghana
when the new core was brought in and
installed into the reactor.
The highly enriched uranium core had already been taken out.
But when I visited it had not
left the country yet.
One of the nuclear regulators from Ghana remarked
when we passed by it--somewhat
mysteriously--he said there's a little
God under there
that's like what do you mean and he
whispered to me that's it that's the old
core so it was not something that they
wanted to have lying around.
Finally last month in August the plane
took the uranium back to China. Now the
Chinese and Americans are going to work
together in the next conversion which is
going to be in Nigeria, this coming
spring. People hope that this will lead
to more cooperation
among the nuclear weapons scientists.